welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled biomarkers in breast
cancer
current practice opportunities and unmet
needs
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
jeffrey peppercorn dr peppercorn is a
medical oncologist
specializing in breast cancer who
conducts research related to health
policy
bioethics and cancer survivorship he
serves as the director
of the mgh cancer center supportive care
and survivorship program
and is the associate professor of
medicine at harvard medical school
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen if any
questions arise during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr jeffrey
peppercorn i will now turn the
presentation
over to him
thank you jen for that introduction uh
it's a pleasure to be able to speak to
you all today
uh virtually about biomarkers in breast
cancer
i'll be covering current practice uh
opportunities
and unmet needs this program is to
provide the support for this program is
provided by abbott
information is based on my
interpretation the evidence and my
clinical experience
as a breast cancer medical oncologist so
we'll go over today management of early
stage breast cancer and the role of
biomarkers
what i call defining the holy grail of
the perfect biomarker that we don't
really have yet
survivorship care after early stage
breast cancer the role of tumor markers
current practice and guidelines
and screening for recurrence uh
as well as a little bit about
circulating tumor dna which is a hot new
area
we'll cover biomarkers and they're used
in metastatic breast cancer
current practice and needs and then
summary and some of the
needs for future research in this area
so the holy grail what do i mean by this
well as some of you may know 94 of
breast cancer is curable
so most patients come to us with cancer
in their breasts or their axilla
and there's at least a potential for
cure now unfortunately six percent of
patients
have distant disease at diagnosis stage
four disease it's treatable but it's not
curable
but this first graphic here shows the
the patients in yellow that's that's
representing
uh 94 of people who are potentially
curable
and we know that with appropriate
therapy 80 will be cured
but we don't know who they are and
importantly we don't know who are the
ones who actually have microscopic
disease
who need our interventions to get that
chance of cure so if you look at the
next
group there the group that are truly at
risk for reoccurrence is not the whole
crowd
of yellow patients those people in green
represent
the roughly uh 40 that are at risk and
if we had a biomarker to identify those
we could leave the other 60 alone after
their surgery
but we don't have that so we treat
everybody and then
we know that we're going to cure about
half the patients who are at risk
so again we don't know who they are and
unfortunately
all of our patients experience fear of
recurrence
and we worry about them as well and
if we had a biomarker who could identify
who these people were say a blood test
that would tell us you know you're
cancer-free don't worry about it
you're still at risk we need to
intervene and give you the best chance
of cure this is what we're looking for
this is what i would call the holy grail
but as you'll see we're not quite there
yet so
um just showing the groups here so
why what are we doing with biomarkers
well biomarkers are critical to define
breast cancer subtypes so this is some
work
from sorely and chuck peru published
back in 2003 where they looked at
gene expression and by looking at the
genes that are overexpressed and
underexpressed
they were able to characterize molecular
subtypes of breast cancer
and they showed us at least five major
subtypes
luminal a's luminal b's her2 positives
so-called basal likes and normal likes
and probably if we get more refined in
this there's more
biologically important subtypes that we
can identify right now
in the lab and with genes that we can
target for intervention
but where are we in the clinic we really
are only using immunohistochemistry
primarily
to identify three distinct breast cancer
subtypes so these are we look at the
estrogen receptors
progesterone receptors and her2 and if
they're estrogen receptor or
progesterone receptor positive called
endocrine receptor positive
that is one subtype tends to have
a relatively better prognosis sometimes
doesn't need chemotherapy
the kind that uh can recur even 10
20 30 years later that's certainly
better than recurring the first two or
three years
then we've got the her2 subtype that
i'll talk a little more about
which has a more aggressive
biology and a worse prognosis unless you
use special drugs directed at her2
therapy in which case the prognosis is
now quite good
and the third is the triple negative
subtype also sometimes referred to as
basal like
but all of those that we're calling
triple negative are not really the basal
like at the molecular level
um so we're checking these three
subtypes and i put on here the two
references to the um
the asco cap guidelines to reflect the
fact that even today with these three
subtypes
we're still constantly questioning how
do we really define this breast cancer
and what this what this patient has
so we had new updates on how to identify
estrogen and progesterone receptors
correctly and how to characterize
patients correctly
in just 2020 we had new updates on how
to define her2
in 2018 and it's a constantly moving
target
so i'm going to retreat a little bit to
just basic definitions of biomarkers to
tell you what we're looking for
first there's prognostic biomarkers and
there's predictive biomarkers and in
common english these words basically
mean the same thing
but when we're talking about biomarkers
for prognostic we mean
can this be used to understand the
chance of a disease outcome
such as relapse or survival can can it
um can we prognosticate about what will
happen
for example you know biomarker x
suggests this patient has a 30
greater chance of cancer relapse after
surgery or perhaps one that has a
30 percent greater chance of cure for a
predictive biomarker
we're talking about something that can
be used to select a particular therapy
so this biomarker suggests that a
patient will have a 50
chance of response to treatment with
drug x whatever that is
and as you'll see we're moving towards
having we've got many things that are
prognostic
they're most useful to us when they're
predictive about a specific therapy
when it comes to the framework for use
of biomarkers our guidelines committees
such as the american society of clinical
oncology and nccn
look at three major things first the
analytic validity
this is the ability to accurately
measure the feature of interest the
protein mutation etc
both in the lab and in patients can you
accurately and reliably measure the
biomarker in blood samples
is the assay sensitive and specific is
the result reproducible
then there's the clinical validity this
is the ability to reliably predict the
outcome of interest
can this biomarker reliably predict
recurrence or worsening of metastatic
breast cancer
and what is the false negative or false
positive rate and then finally the
the top standard would be clinical
utility meaning i can use this biomarker
to guide my management of patients
and it's proven that if i do that it'll
improve outcomes
so can it guide interventions such as
continuing a treatment longer
or switching to a new therapy and if i
do that and i use the biomarker
is survival or some other important
disease outcome improved compared to
my practice when i don't use the test so
that's clinical utility
oops move us along
so biomarkers are used in breast cancer
to evaluate
prognosis we one of the jobs as a
medical oncologist that we're always
doing we meet a new patient
is we're trying to estimate the risk of
recurrence and we base it
on individual prognostic factors these
this lists the prognostic factors for
early stage breast cancer at least some
of them
so there's lymph node status size of the
cancer
and something called lymphovascular
invasion and i think of these
largely as the geography where was the
cancer when we found it
um we also have things like the grade of
the cancer on a scale of one to three
the hormone receptor status estrogen and
progesterone receptors
the her2 new status also other
biomarkers such as chi
67 which is a marker proliferation and
as you'll hear about these multi-gene
panels
and patient age with with younger women
particularly those under 35
having a worse prognosis say than those
who are above 65.
um you can think of these later criteria
all as things related to biology
and in particular these hormone
receptors her2nu ki 67
and multi-gene panels are what we're
talking about when we refer to
biomarkers
so we can use biomarkers to
individualize therapy
um so precision therapy is now talked
about in oncology it's really just been
the last
couple years that we've been using that
term it's kind of a hot turn
but i would argue that in breast cancer
uh way before my time
clinicians have been using precision or
personalized therapy in some ways for
over 100 years
so i'm going to give you a brief window
into the history of what i'd call the
first biomarker driven therapy in
oncology
back in 1895 a surgeon george beatson
he didn't know anything about estrogen
at the time but he figured out there was
some hormone in the body such that
he could remove the ovaries from
premenopausal women
and metastatic breast cancer in other
parts of the body
would regress so that's been published
and well documented
now for 125 years um in the 20s
uh estrogen the hormone was discovered
and purified
and decades later at the university of
chicago dr jensen
identified and purified the estrogen
receptor and so ever since then we've
been able to test for that
oops um in 1971
is when we first identified solidly the
estrogen receptor as a prognostic factor
in breast cancer
there's a lot of papers it's a little
hard to pinpoint the exact date of this
but around then is when you start to see
papers saying
you know people who overexpress breast
cancer do better
than people who don't express breast
cancer who overexpress the estrogen
receptor
do better than those who don't express
the estrogen receptor
then ever since 1977 we've had my friend
tamoxifen
a drug that we still use in clinic today
it's a non-steroidal anti-estrogen drug
now called a selective
estrogen receptor modulator or serm and
it was approved back then by the fda for
treatment of advanced breast cancer
meaning breast cancer
that spread to other parts of the body
um it was then
shown uh to be useful as an adjective
therapy for our patients with early
stage disease potentially curable
back in 1985
and it was proven
we identified in 1998 that it was best
for er positive breast cancer
it was still considered experimental for
er negative or poor breast cancer
and really it wasn't until this was sort
of very early in my career
until 2005 for a drug we've had since
1977
that we realized that er was a very
important biomarker and you should
really only use tamoxifen in patients
who are er positive not in those
who are er or estrogen receptor negative
so it took a long time to get where we
are today and as i told you we're still
defining
as of 2020 who's really estrogen
receptor positive and what should the
threshold be
and how should we do the testing for
that biomarker so it is complicated
but estrogen progesterone receptors are
both biomarkers and both of them
relate to the endocrine sensitivity of a
tumor and the drugs we should use
they can inform prognosis you can
improve prognosis with increased
expression
they can predict response to therapy for
early stage breast cancer
and they can predict response to therapy
for advanced breast cancer so
just i'm not going to go in great detail
into the treatment of breast cancer
but again just to show you how these
these biomarkers are used
for a postmenopausal woman uh whose
estrogen receptor positive her2 negative
will use a estrogen lowering drug an
aromatase inhibitor
for anywhere from five to ten years
for uh pre-menopausal women we will tend
to use tamoxifen alone
or we'll use that plus ovarian
suppression or sometimes an aromatase
inhibitor
plus ovarian expression for five to ten
years and this has been shown to reduce
the risk of recurrence
compared to surgery alone by an
additional 30 to 50 so quite a powerful
intervention for metastatic or advanced
breast cancer
we tend to treat uh premenopausal
patients all of them get ovarian
suppression and then patients whether
they're younger or older will get an
aromatase inhibitor
we're now adding new drugs on top of
that um to block
mechanisms of endocrine resistance with
the cdk46 inhibitors
we're using a drug called fulbestring
which is a selective estrogen receptor
degrader
and we tend to use multiple lines of
endocrine therapy for as long as they
keep working
and eventually we need to move on to
chemotherapy and the biomarker becomes
less important
but median survival for metastatic er
positive breast cancer
is now about five years and many
patients will do well for 10 years or
longer
um this is just sorry this is just a
slide
um showing you the benefits of tamoxifen
compared to control
published many years ago there's about a
33
reduction in the risk of recurrence
overall and a 25 reduction in breast
cancer risk from tamoxifen
and since then we've played with
extending the duration there's
additional benefits you can eke out by
adding ovarian suppression
or extending it from five to ten years
in select patients
so what about other biomarkers well this
is what i would call sort of that was
the if that was the first biomarker i
would say this is maybe the example of
an optimal biomarker
to guide precision cancer therapy um so
again walk you through the history and
get my slides to work
um so back in 1987 this doesn't go quite
as ancient as the other one
but dennis slayman at ucla recognized
that the reason some women with breast
cancer did worse than others even though
the size was the same and the stage was
the same
was that they overexpressed this her2
protein or the
or they had amplification of the her2
gene so it's a
negative prognostic factor known in the
80s
then he and his lab helped develop the
monoclonal antibody trastuzumab
against the her2 protein back in 96 it
took some time to develop it but there
were single arm
studies showing that this drug was
effective
and then we had randomized controlled
trials published in 2001
showing that there was improved survival
five months improved survival
uh by adding the drug trastuzumab
compared to chemotherapy alone
so for for a disease where survival was
about two years
extending it by an additional almost
half a year was a
meaningful result uh resulting in this
drug getting approved back in 98
and then the biggest impact i would
argue was when we did studies showing
that this could reduce the
risk of even getting metastatic disease
in the first place
for people with early-stage
her2-positive breast cancer with a 50
reduction in risk it was approved in
2006 for node positive
breast cancer and in 2008 for node
negative breast cancer so even for our
lowest risk patients
with her2 positive disease we are now
using this
um so it is a biomarker that informs our
prognosis you do
unless you get special treatment you do
worse if you have this
it predicts response to her2 targeted
therapy such that prognosis is now i
would argue quite good
then we now amazingly have seven
approved drugs
i remember this thing was just
identified back in 87 the first drug
approved in 98. today we have seven
approved drugs
two monoclonal antibodies three small
molecule inhibitors and some novel drug
antibody conjugates
the um the graph there which hopefully
uh you can see
clearly just shows the difference
between chemotherapy alone the best
chemotherapy we had
circa 2005 where for these patients with
lymph node positive her2 positive
disease
the cure rate was about 65
and then you added this single drug a
monoclonal antibody suddenly the cure
rate is up
above 85 so that's that's what we're
looking for in precision therapy
throughout oncology
biomarker driven therapy with a highly
effective drug
and and the prognosis has only gotten
better as we've been able to add to that
so unmet needs what about triple
negative breast cancer
so-called because it's negative for
estrogen receptor progesterone receptor
and her2 essentially doesn't have a
biomarker
there's no there's other things that
we're starting to use in advanced
disease
but in early stage disease there's
really nothing else that we're using in
clinic
and and we know we know that we're not
doing well enough here
um the science which is not yet
translated to the clinic shows us that
we're clearly looking at more than one
disease
currently grouped is triple negative
some studies have shown that about 80
percent are truly basal like
based on molecular phenotype uh 15
are normal-like there's some luminal
bees there's some luminal a's there's
even a small amount of her2
uh breast cancer subtypes in there and
there's a whole bunch of potential
biomarkers
we just haven't established their um
their clinical utility yet
to bring them into the clinic so some of
the things that are that are being
looked at
are up regulation of ras and neck pi3
kinase mutations
androgen receptor expression there's
already drugs to target the androgen
receptor
and triple negative disease and some
impressive outcomes in
early phase trials and then somatic brc
brca mutations where we again have
approved drugs
to treat patients with advanced disease
but we're just starting to use them in
studies in early phase disease
not to mention immunotherapy and
questions about who should benefit
so biomarkers can also be used to guide
decisions over
chemotherapy particularly for patients
with er positive lymph node negative
breast cancer
so i'm going to bring you into the
clinic for a minute talk about a case
a 55 year old woman with early stage
breast cancer who's just had a
lumpectomy
her cancer is 1.8 centimeters she's got
two negative sentinel nodes
intermediate grade it's estrogen
receptor positive progesterone
receptor positive her2 negative so we're
clearly going to give our endocrine
therapy that's that's established
and the question is should she do
chemotherapy
so as of 2005 around the time that i
started practice
the calculus be would be that you know
this patient has about a 20
risk of recurrence over the next 10
years with surgery and radiation alone
we could cut this down with endocrine
therapy to about 10 to 12 percent
and chemotherapy might offer an
additional four to five percent
reduction in risk
is it worth it and you can imagine that
having a discussion about are you gonna
undergo chemotherapy
for anywhere from a four to five percent
or maybe a three percent reduction
would take an hour and there was no
right answer and and patients were
looking to us for guidance
and really it's a very difficult
decision um
so it wasn't a very satisfying
discussion but we had to do it and we
had to treat people
um so now there was a clear
unmet need and as a biomarker people
came up with not one single marker but
sort of a multi-gene panel
a multi-gene prognostic assay and a
number of different investigators and
companies did this so today we've got
oncotype dx print cigna endo predict
breast cancer index and
others and all of them do similar things
evaluating some panel anywhere from 70
to 21 genes
that can that are proven to predict
prognosis among patients with early
stage er positive breast cancer who are
treated with endocrine therapy alone
and and they can help us identify
patients who remain at high risk
despite endocrine therapy who need
chemotherapy
so this is a great um this is one of my
favorite graphs
published in the journal of clinical
oncology back in 2006
that kind of explains the power of this
tool this is using the oncotype test
so in panel a you see all patients
in a clinical trial where the patients
were treated either with tamoxifen
or tamoxifen plus chemotherapy and
overall
there was this three to five percent
benefit it was statistically significant
and that's what led to these very
different so it's real but it's tiny
and that led to these very difficult
discussions with our patients
but if you stratify them based on this
biomarker
you find a group that's that has a low
risk oncotype recurrence score
and those patients are going to do well
no matter what you do
they do equally well with or without
chemotherapy
and and you really that whole
conversation would have been pointless
and misleading in some cases so that's
about 50 of all patients
and we're glad we're not treating them
with chemotherapy then
there's this middle group intermediate
risk patients um
according to the recurrence score who do
a little bit worse and it's actually
unclear i mean if you look at the graph
you'd say it's not unclear there's
really no difference but there wasn't
statistical power to say
whether chemotherapy helped them a lot
so hold that point that that group was
uncertain
that's about 25 percent of patients and
then there was this 25 percent group
that were at high risk whereas you can
see there's a large split
in prognosis if you do tamoxifen alone
there's almost a uh
only a 60 chance of cure and you can
boost that up again above 90 if you give
them chemotherapy
and certainly you'd want to identify
those patients and give them
chemotherapy
so i like this because it shows the
power of that biomarker um
then there was a randomized trial
published recently called the taylor x
study
over 10 000 patients trying to help
address among other things
the question of what do we do with that
intermediate group so one thing this
trial did is for the low risk patients
it showed us yes
very reassuringly in a prognostic
fashion they do great
they don't need chemo the score is 11 or
under
but for people who are estrogen receptor
positive and node negative
if their score was 11 to 25 almost 7 000
patients
were randomly assigned to chemotherapy
or no chemotherapy
all of them got endocrine therapy and
what we saw was that there was no
difference with chemotherapy at nine
years
um there was basically an 83 chance of
remaining recurrence free
whether you did chemotherapy or not uh
92
chance of not having it go to distant
places of the body so those recurrences
were mostly in the breast or the axilla
and a 94 chance you'd be alive at nine
years regardless of doing chemotherapy
now uh one caveat there was some
benefit in people at the higher end of
this middle range
if they were premenopausal or under 50
we think some of that at least
is is not the benefit from chemo killing
dividing cells
but from chemo shutting down the ovaries
and and basically
boosting the strength of endocrine
therapy in these patients which may be
why you see a difference in patients
who still have ovarian function those
under 50 and those who are
versus those who are postmenopausal
where chemo didn't add
so that's that's where we are with early
stage breast cancer
questions that are still unanswered are
what about the best biomarker to use for
p
for selecting chemotherapy for patients
with
no positive breast cancer mammal print
has been used and has some
prospective data to help us but in
general we still need better markers
for this highest risk group not to
mention which chemotherapies to use
selection of optimal endocrine therapy
we'd love to know
when we can get away with tamoxifen
alone when we when patients do better
off with aromatase inhibitor and our
premenopausal women
and also since we've now got studies
showing that there's a benefit from
up to 10 years or longer we'd like to
know which patients since these
these medicines have side effects which
patients
really can get away with less than you
know five years or less than five years
they just don't need it which patients
need five which patients need ten
which patients need more than 10 and
then the role of immunotherapy for
high-risk triple negative breast cancer
since those patients
have a very concerning prognosis if it
comes back and we've seen some
hints that immunotherapy can be useful
we'd really like to better understand
who to use it in there's now good data
for neoadjuvant therapy there's many
trials ongoing
in this space but with these trials
we're collecting blood samples and
looking at the tumor to try to figure
out biomarkers to help guide
the use of immunotherapy and other
targeted therapies
so
biomarkers can also be used selectively
to evaluate symptoms in breast cancer
survivors
so as you heard at the beginning i'm a
breast cancer doc
and one of my jobs is running the
survivorship program and i can tell you
that most patients with breast cancer do
survive and there's a lot of things we
worry about in the ongoing care of these
patients
their mental health emotional health
chronic symptoms they may have
late effects of therapy such as cardiac
toxicity
wellness and lifestyle issues are they
fit are they eating well
social and practical issues and a big
one
is screening for cancer recurrence
i will tell you that 80 to 90 of
patients are cured but
a hundred percent worry about the risk
of recurrence understandably as i think
all of us
would um and the question is what can
and should we do
about that this is a very frequent topic
of conversation in clinic
you know are we going to get scans are
there blood tests what can we do
so tumor markers are very appealing
these are substances typically proteins
detected in blood that may be able to
indicate the presence or growth of a
cancer
so an ideal tumor marker um which i will
give you the punch line we do not have
yet but an ideal tumor marker
would only be found when the cancer is
there and you'd be able to perfectly
distinguish patients with cancer from
those without so if i check this lab
and you don't have this marker you're
home free that's it
you can you don't even need to maybe
come back to the oncology clinic um
on the other hand if you have it what it
means can vary is it going to come back
in two years it's going to come back in
10 years
but we want to know that we want to
address it and maybe monitor differently
ideally the level of elevation of the
marker how high it is
might tell us how to guide screening for
cancer in the first place
what the cancer burden is and what
intensity of therapy to use
it might demonstrate therapeutic success
in other words the marker's high
i give radiation or i give chemotherapy
it goes down or it goes to zero
i know i've been successful and as i
said it can be used to screen for
occurrence so there are some
effective and clinically useful
biomarkers
in oncology we just really don't have
any in breast cancer yet so
think of psa for prostate cancer
use of the m protein for myeloma hcg and
some testicular cancers
and in fact one that we are looking at
in breast cancer cea
is actually used and it's in the
guidelines for colon cancer
so this um
this biomarker was identified in 1965
there were studies then of colon cancers
that found that
virtually all cancer cells seem to
express cea and the healthy tissue did
not so that was you know as i said a
perfect biomarker
now as it's turned out over time this is
not entirely true with our modern assays
but it's still a very good marker
particularly for colon cancer
and elevated levels can be found in
other cancer types
so certainly other cancers of the gi
tract
breast cancer medullary thyroid
carcinoma
liver lung ovarian pancreatic and
prostate cancers
um whoops my slide jumped sorry
um as i said it's a proven marker in
colon cancer management elevation after
surgery
um predicts recurrence but it's also
associated with non-cancer medical
issues kidney disease
hypothyroid lung disease liver disease
even cigarette smoking and it can be
elevated even in three percent of people
who don't seem to have any condition
so it is not perfect it does seem to be
involved in inflammation it does have
some cancer specific functions
um but it doesn't perfectly distinguish
as i said
um we also have other biomarkers that
we're looking at in breast cancer
ca 15-3 and ca 27-23
these are basically both measures of the
muck one protein and the numbers and the
different assays
you know different centers i've worked
out i've tended to use one versus the
other
but this just refers to the antibodies
that are used in the assay to find mach
1.
muck one is a transmembrane
transmembrane glycoprotein
that is altered and overexpressed in
multiple cancer types
and it plays a role in progression of
disease cancer survival and resistance
to chemotherapy
it can be elevated in breast cancer but
also in ovarian uterine lung colon and
other cancer types
and it can be elevated in people with
benign breast disease benign ovarian
cysts
liver disease and up to five percent of
healthy people so again
if you find it very elevated it could
mean that there's cancer there and it's
certainly concerning
but especially if it's slightly elevated
it could be many other things and it's
not a perfect screening tool
is it prognostic yes there's many
studies like this one from
2015 they looked at 432 patients
with early stage breast cancer they
measured it before surgery
and then every six to 12 months and if
you could as you can see
prognosis was was uh somewhat worse
if one of them was elevated and
significantly worse if both
were elevated however close to 40
percent who had elva
who had elevated levels still had not
recurred 10 years later
so you wouldn't really want to use this
in clinic find it elevated and be
scaring 40
of people who are going to be fine 10
years later
that is the challenge in asymptomatic
patients so
there's been a lot of studies now um
looking at more intensive screening
in patients and cancer survivors
constantly asking the question
can't we do more than just you know wait
for the cancer to come back
or wait for symptoms to show up well the
answer is unfortunately
not clear there's not much more that we
know we can do so far
so the first trial the givio trial was
in italy
um over a thousand patients and they
compared more intensive screening which
in that trial was defined as liver
function tests blood tests
plus a chest x-ray versus clinical
visits alone
and it made no difference in survival or
the quality of life
at six year follow-up another study done
around the same time in italy i'm not
sure what was going on in italy with
these investigators that time
but another study looked at over a
thousand patients and they compared
more intensive imaging studies chest
x-ray and a bone scheme
um versus clinic visits alone and again
saw no difference in survival either
five or ten years
so we don't get imaging studies if
people don't have symptoms
there haven't been a lot of studies of
tumor markers but one of the best ones
was a nearly 500 person randomized trial
where patients either had a routine
clinical visit
or clinical visit plus tumor markers
liver function tests and chest x-ray
every six months and then scans whether
they had symptoms or not every two years
again there was no difference in
survival at least at the four-year
mark so what are the
guidelines these are from 1996 you'll
notice but they still apply today
cea and ca 15-3 are not sensitive enough
to detect all micro-metastatic disease
so this is not the holy grail
that's why the frenchman in the corner
is taunting us as he did in the movie
the holy grail
for those who appreciate that they can
be elevated in healthy people without
metastatic disease
they might be elevated years before
disease shows up so it's unclear if
identifying that helps in any way
30 percent of people with known
metastatic disease do not have elevation
so it was recommended in those
guidelines to not check people without
symptoms
this was address this has been addressed
multiple times in the choosing wisely
campaign
trying to inform us all how we can save
money without
adversely affecting cancer care one of
the things that was recommended was not
to perform surveillance testing like
biomarkers or imaging
for asymptomatic patients who've been
treated with breast cancer with curative
intent
uh some limits in this data however
there's clear evidence that tumor
markers can detect recurrence early
so their utility is not their lack of
utility
is somewhat suspect many new drugs since
2005 have been developed
when those most recent large randomized
controlled trials of intensive
surveillance were done so
is it possible that if you found disease
earlier now even though it was
asymptomatic
and you use some of our new drugs that
you might make a difference in outcomes
we actually don't know
and certainly one of the things that
concerns me most as an oncologist
is that there might be differences in
the utility for people who are at higher
risk either on the basis of their
clinical stage
or their biology you know this these
studies of a thousand patients if you
included
vast majority of patients who are lower
risk or er positive
then they're not going to occur no
matter what you do and you might be
swamping the benefits of early
or intensive staging in those with
higher risk disease but
but screening can lead to harm there can
be false positive results
additional tests and biopsies may be
done
and we need evidence that this kind of
thing will help before considering
patients without
symptoms so i'd say this should be done
in a clinical trial
not in routine practice so what do i do
with this data and the limitations in
the current data
in my practice for early stage breast
cancer well here's an example
the case is a 50 year old woman with a
history of left-sided invasive lobular
breast cancer
it's three centimeters involving two
lymph nodes
it's estrogen receptor positive her2
negative
uh she had a lumpectomy chemotherapy and
radiation
she's now on endocrine therapy with
aromatase inhibitor for three years
and she comes into me reporting two
months of abdominal pain
she's seen in her local emergency
department and the ct scan of her
uh abdomen doesn't show any clear
evidence of metastatic disease
so what do we do she does have a few
small liver and lung nodules
too small to characterize and you know
which is
not uncommon and she still feels unwell
so i would do an exam i would repeat i'm
planning to repeat imaging because we
have to do that
in three to six months and i would check
tumor markers
and if they're normal that's very that's
very reassuring
although it doesn't really change the
need for uh follow-up i'd still get
those scans to be sure she's okay
but i would i would assume actually that
it's probably not
cancer recurrence now if they're
markedly elevated which is the main
reason i would be getting the test
i would be very worried for recurrence i
would clearly follow her differently get
further imaging at that time
follow her more closely if her symptoms
persist i might even consider surgical
exploration
and we might if they keep going up we
might change endocrine therapy and see
if there's a response
now the problem comes if they're
slightly abnormal this would probably
still lead to closer follow-up
but it may not as i've suggested
indicate cancer recurrence
and it could lead to increased anxiety
so that's where you run some risk and
usually
if i'm going to order tumor markers for
patients with symptoms
which again is a choice not addressed in
those guidelines
i discuss these three possible results
with patients and i sort of warn them
that if they're slightly elevated this
may create anxiety and it doesn't
necessarily mean that there's going to
be a problem down the road
i mean in my experience it often doesn't
mean that there's a problem down the
road
um so uh what's new
what's coming well this is a relatively
new technology
not in the clinic yet outside of
clinical trials but ct dna
or circulating tumor dna is about
detecting dna from cancer cells
in a blood test it's also called a
liquid biopsy
because we can detect the molecular
features of the cancer and it can be
used to predict prognosis
theoretically guide therapy evaluate
response to therapy
and detect recurrence of cancer in
clinical studies
but we need evidence of clinical utility
and improvement in outcomes before we
use it
so this is the kind of evidence we have
right now this was a study of 170
patients from five
hospitals in the uk where they looked at
prospective collection of ctdna
patients with early stage breast cancer
with had samples collected at the time
of surgery
then every three months times one year
and then every six months
dna was extracted from the biopsy
studied from mutations
followed by blood tests with pcr assays
detect that patient's
specific somatic mutations as a possible
sign of recurrence so first
they looked at people at baseline among
80 patients
they found that they could detect ctdna
and 51
of people at diagnosis and actually that
was prognostic
it did it did identify patients at a
higher risk of relapse
over the next five years even more
compelling
when you follow people over time and
look for their specific mutation their
tumor
to pop up again in the blood test this
happened in 16
of patients in this study and in those
patients as you can see from this graph
there was a big difference in prognosis
if it never came up if you had a
specific mutation
and they couldn't find it in the blood
your prognosis over the
six years in this study was excellent
very few recurrences
but if you were in the other group who
is ctdna positive
by by five years
you know roughly all but 30 percent had
recurred
so that is a um potentially very
important tool
you can imagine then that at the time
that you first detected
the ct dna you would love to put these
people in a clinical trial or start an
intervention
and see if that can make a difference so
that's the next step so as the
investigators here said
our results demonstrate clinical
validity for ct dna mutation tracking
with
pcr but they do not demonstrate clinical
utility
without evidence that mutation tracking
can improve patient outcomes
our results should not be recommended
yet for routine clinical practice
so that's where we are so i'm going to
turn
now and talk about
take a sip of water and then talk about
biomarkers being used to guide therapy
in metastatic breast cancer
so metastatic breast cancer is incurable
but has a highly variable prognosis
so for most of my career at least till
recent years
median survival was only about two years
but even then
there were rare patients who were
survived 10 years 20 years later i've
seen people in my clinic
who didn't start with me but they were
given bad news 20 years ago and they're
still doing okay
so highly variable and now the average
is closer to five years
after diagnosis of metastatic disease
for people with er positive disease
and with her2 positive disease with
modern therapy unfortunately
for people with triple negative breast
cancer it's still really in the one to
two
year range and closer to one and there's
some very aggressive cancers
um that are that are concerning that we
need better biomarkers and better
treatments for
so we treat metastatic cancer based on
subtype based on these biomarkers
if they're er positive we use serial
lines of endocrine therapy until they're
resistant
and then we move to chemotherapy and now
we're using some other therapies um
not with clear all with clear biomarkers
but cdk46
mtor as you'll hear about pi3 kinase
inhibitors which do have a biomarker
for her2 positive disease we're using
her2 targeted therapy
usually although not always with a chemo
backbone and now we've got multiple new
drugs
and we're starting to explore use of
therapy in her2 low patients with that
as a biomarker
and in triple negative metastatic breast
cancer we're predominantly using
chemotherapy
but now in first line setting we're
using immunotherapy as a standard option
for people who are pdl one positive
and we're using parp inhibitors for
triple negative
or any breast cancer that's brca one or
two positive
so the 2015 asco guidelines say that at
the diagnosis of metastatic disease we
should do a biopsy
to confirm the diagnosis check our
standard clinical biomarkers
er pr and her2 to guide therapy they
highlight the fact
that the estrogen receptor status can
actually change up to 10
of the time between the initial tumor
and the metastatic disease which can
come years later
progesterone receptor can change even
more often and her2
which is so important to guide therapy
can change up to six percent of the time
this could be due to the assay sometimes
so that's a concern but it's also been
documented to happen due to mutation
or tumor heterogeneity where one clone
survives and recurs
therapy is guided by biomarker status of
the metastatic disease
not the original tumor and as of 2015
in these guidelines there was no
additional biomarkers that were deemed
useful
to select therapy um not kai 67
p53 they did not recommend using the
next generate generation sequencing or
molecular profiling panels
which i would argue are now standard
five years later
um and they did not consider new data on
brca pi3 kinase and esr one
that has really merged primarily since
that time um so
that's fair um i'm going to talk about
some of these biomarkers i'm actually
not going to go into brca which is its
own interesting story
but suffice it to say that parp
inhibitors are now improved
for people who have brca mutations as
one biomarker
and this is another interesting one the
pi3 kinase mutation
this is a lipid kinase part of the pi3
kinase akt
mtor cell signaling pathway uh having a
mutation of pi3 kinase conveys worst
prognosis
prognosis metastatic breast cancer and
resistance to endocrine therapy
and it's found in about 40 of all er
positive her2-negative metastatic breast
cancers
so it's uh prognostic now what about
predicting
predicting a value of using a specific
drug so there's been lots of pi3 kinase
drugs uh
in clinical trials and breast cancer
over the years but the first one
approved
is alpha licip so the solar one trial
took over 500 patients and randomly
assigned
those assigned them to fulvestrine an
estrogen receptor degrader endocrine
therapy
plus or minus this pi3 kinase inhibitor
and if you did not have a pi3 kinase
mutation as shown in the bottom here
there was no difference so the biomarker
is critically important
but if you have the pi3 kinase mutation
there was a
over four month difference in
progression-free survival
uh close to six months versus 11 months
and clinical benefit the chance that at
six months
you're going to have either responsive
disease or at least stable disease
went up from 45 percent to 62 so
certainly if i'm a patient
that's very clinically meaningful it was
fda approved in 2019
so we have it in the clinic now but
actually although
we are trying to uh do this routinely
testing for pi3 kinase
mutations is not quite automated it's
not just as a doctor
every time i send a pathology sample i
get this result back
so it just shows you where we are i mean
we can get it we just have to order it
um but it's not quite where we are for
er pr her2 so our pathologist for
pathologists in the audience you know
you would never read out a breast cancer
case and not tell them the estrogen
receptors
um but at least at some institutions
we're not yet getting routine
pi3 kinase testing and when there's a
drug and you're going to use that
mutation to guide therapy
it's important to know this but it's a
rapidly evolving field as i said
similarly the pdl1 programmed
cell death ligand is a cell surface
protein that inhibits the immune
response to cancer
it's expressed in up to 40 of patients
with triple negative breast cancer or
triple negative breast cancers i should
say and expression in this case
correlates with improved outcomes so you
can think of it maybe that um
uh if it's overexpressed maybe it's
because the immune system is attacking
the cancer
and it's trying to block that so there's
drugs to target this
and try to let the immune system attack
the cancer more effectively
there's you know everybody i think in
the audience probably knows the story of
immunotherapy throughout oncology
but in breast cancer the first drug
approved is a tessalizumab
this is from a randomized trial of 900
patients who got either
regular chemotherapy with nab paclitaxel
uh or nap packing taxol plus the
immunotherapy with the teslizumab
overall there was a modest two-month
difference in survival
you know about 19 versus 21 months not
that impressive
but if you used the biomarker
and you said what about people who had
more than one percent
pdl1 expression you saw a
seven month difference in survival so
you know i'm only going to survive 18
months or if i take this drug first line
i'm going to survive 25 months now again
certainly not good enough
but that is a very meaningful difference
and that's why this drug was fda
approved
um in march 2019 and just as we saw
earlier with trastuzumab where it had
about a five-month difference
in the advanced cancer setting and it's
you know made a big difference there
but it was when we moved it up front
that we saw a very impressive difference
in the cure rate
so that's what we're hoping for this or
similar drugs that's the subject of
ongoing
studies
so sorry um so the nccn guidelines now
in 2020 recommend the following
biomarkers
um for any patient getting first-line
disease brca testing to see if they
should be exposed to a parp inhibitor as
one of their treatments
if they're er positive her2 negative in
the second line
testing for a pi3 kinase mutation again
seen in about 40 percent of er positive
her2 negative patients
because you would want to consider the
drug alkalism in triple negative
patients first line it's recommended you
test for pdl one expression as i've just
been talking about
and then there's two others that they
mention for select circumstances you'll
notice
the prevalence of these for both of them
is about one in a thousand
so i would not call this standard but
certainly may want to consider it
and it's in the guidelines for those
reasons so ntrk
fusion um where we now have specific
drugs that can be very effective if you
have that one in a thousand patients
it can make a big difference for them
although still not curable or
if they have microsatellite high or
deficient in
mismatched repair again rare but the
immunotherapy pembrolizumab has been
proven to help those patients regardless
of whether it's breast cancer lung
cancer or anything else
so we're getting these if we send the
multi-gene panels which as i said i
think is now standard
um but we still have to request it it's
not that if i
see a patient and um i you know they go
to a biopsy
we diagnose metastatic disease that this
is automatically run you have to sign
specific consent for it
specifically request the test but i
think within
a few years it will be standard on all
patients the way things are going
and lastly as a breast cancer doc i want
to talk about esr1
because if i had one other thing that i
could have routinely right now it would
be this one
but it's not yet on that list of
recommended biomarkers
this the the estrogen receptor is
encoded by the esr1 gene
which in initial breath primary breast
cancer is very rarely mutated
so it's not a big problem although it
can be in our initial breast cancer
patients
but up upwards of 50 percent of our
patients with metastatic disease
can have alterations in esr1 as a
mechanism of acquired resistance
and when they have it we know that these
are the patients who do best with cdk46
inhibitors
or with fulvestrine instead of an
aromatase inhibitor
um and there's new drugs in clinical
trials
like fulvestrine but but presumably more
powerful
so these are coming along now it's not
yet standard in clinic but since
clinically
i do face a choice sometimes between
giving a patient with metastatic disease
an aromatase inhibitor versus
fulvestrine not to mention putting them
on cdk46 inhibitor although we usually
do that in all cases
i would like to have the sr1 status and
we can get that as part of the testing
that is available so we also
are thinking about biomarkers to
evaluate response to therapy and
metastatic breast cancer
this is just a brief review of our
standard practice we diagnose them
we determine the subtype we evaluate for
some of the select biomarkers as you've
heard
and then we take our best guess we pick
a drug a regimen we evaluate the
toxicity
you know how are they tolerating it we
see them every four to six weeks how are
they doing
and we scan them every two to three
months and we learn at those two to
three or sometimes four month intervals
whether the disease is getting worse or
not and whether we need to switch
therapy
so we've got a clear opportunity for
early evaluation with a biomarker or
blood test that maybe we could get
at every four to six week visit that
might give us
a early clue about whether we need to
move the scans up or if they're doing
fine maybe we can move the scans back
and it could help us in a relatively
non-invasive
non-toxic way so there are tumor markers
that we can use to evaluate response to
therapy
this is from a recent study of just to
demonstrate among
uh nearly 50 patients who had
her2-positive metastatic breast cancer
undergoing their first line of treatment
and the investigators just followed
both the cea ca 15-3
and another biomarker that i haven't
discussed called the serum extracellular
domain of her2 which in this particular
subtype
has been shown to be useful as you see
over time
in general for all of these patients
look varied between patients
the trend is down so as you're giving
effective therapy we have very effective
therapies
in her2 positive disease the biomarkers
tend to go down
it does that does in fact correlate with
response on imaging
so people who have a fantastic response
although rare
have a large decline in their tumor
markers
people who have a partial response tend
to have the markers going down
people whose scans are stable tended to
have stable
um tumor markers and people whose cancer
is worse
tend to have the marker going up so you
could use these blood tests
as a adjunct of an early predictor of
what's going to happen
now the problem has been known for a
long time this is a study from 30 years
ago
looking at the kinetics of tumor marker
response in breast cancer
looking whoops looking at ca and ca 15-3
as you can see in the initial weeks it
tended to go
up then it was basically stable back to
baseline at week four
and only five six and beyond did it
start to go down so this is you would
not want to
have tested at week two seen the marker
going up decided it's not working and
switched to something
because this patient ultimately
responded to this treatment
um so these are the 1996 asco guidelines
based on data like this
which which highlight the fact that
there's a good
but not perfect correlation with
response to therapy you know about
70 to 80 of people who are responding
will have decreased tumor markers
about 75 percent of those with stable
cancer who have stable
markers 75 80 percent with progressive
cancer will have increased tumor markers
but it's not perfect and early in
treatment as i just showed you
it can rise so they recommend actually
not at least within
four weeks and being cautious if you're
doing it within the first four to six
weeks even
and never really relying on one value
for all of these reasons
but if there's a persistent trend over
time that usually correlates with
progressive disease
and you might be seeing that before you
get scenes
um so they recommend they they highlight
the fact that in terms of switching to a
new therapy
this is always based on clinical
evaluation
of disease progression response and
there's no evidence that changing
therapy
solely on the basis of biomarkers
improves health outcomes
quality of life or cost effectiveness i
should highlight this is not from the 96
guidelines this is from the 2015
guideline so this is basically our
current
guidelines we're operating under um they
do point out
that ca ca 15-3 and ca 2729
may contribute to decisions for
metastatic breast cancer they say
there's not clear you know from clinical
trials
solid enough evidence of clinical
utility but there's
there's a lot of clinical experience and
informal consensus that this can be
helpful
and they say that it's also reasonable
if clinicians prefer not to for them not
to use these markers so it's a choice
you just have to know what you're
getting into
what do i do i view it as a three-legged
stool and i really use this metaphor
when i talk about it with patients i'm
always
going to think about what the patient
looks like what they're telling me their
symptoms and their exam
there's one evidence of are they
responding or not how are they doing
i'm going to use tumor markers but i
don't over interpret them
and i check them over time and i try not
to pay attention to one isolated value
but if there's a clear trend
that will be meaningful to me um in
either direction
and i use scans i put scans are probably
the most objective piece of this but i
put them all together
to decide clinically what's going on
so what about circulating tumor cells in
fairness i just want to comment on them
because this is a technology
still being used in research i think it
still holds a lot of promise but it's
been a little disappointing
in some of the studies today so these
were identified in autopsy specimens of
people cancer
back in the 1860s you could look on the
microscope and see tumor cells
the concept is not new and we found ways
to do a blood test
and and pull out these circulating tumor
cells and we know
that they can be seen in up to 25
percent of people at diagnosis
and that a high level of them is not a
great thing
so it's not perfect but it can predict
your
risk of recurrence in metastatic breast
cancer
um similarly there's good prognostic
studies published in new england journal
medicine back in 2004
study of 177 patients that showed if you
have more of five of these
in your 7.5 mls of blood this is worse
prognosis for example um more than five
showed uh people people had more than
five had eight months overall survival
compared to
18 months in those with less than five
with the treatments of that time
so a clinical trial was done
to see if these would be you know
clinically useful in practice to guide
switching of therapy this was swog
so500 a randomized trial of nearly 300
patients
all of whom all of whom had high ctcs
and they were randomized to doing an
early switch
uh based on the response or staying on
therapy and unfortunately
using ctcs to guide the decision to
switch showed no difference in
progression-free
oral overall survival after whoops or
after after four months
so they're still being used in research
but they're not generally being used in
clinical practice
this was published in jco back in 2014.
um
i want to make one comment on liquid
biopsy versus tumor biopsy because this
is a hot area i've already alluded to
this
certainly there's times we still need a
tumor biopsy particularly when we're
seeing something on a scan we don't know
what it is
and we want to make the diagnosis of
metastatic disease but there are risks
to invasive biopsies
now biopsy in the breast is relatively
safe can cause pain
minor bleeding but really almost zero
risk of serious complications
i'm talking about metastatic disease the
liver um a study of 150 patients
showed seven percent have moderate pain
no major bleeds
smaller number of minor bleeds study and
actually have had patients
who've undergone a liver biopsy one not
too long ago who
unfortunately had a complication big
bleed ended up in the hospital she was
fine
out the next day but i do not view this
as a benign procedure
and lung biopsies are even more
problematic with anywhere from 10 to 15
of pneumothorax again patients are
usually fine but they might need a chest
tube they might need to be in the
hospital
so these are not risk-free um liquid
biopsies which basically means a blood
test
are far less invasive i mean it's like
having you know your blood drawn
we've all had that essentially zero risk
close to zero pain
liquid biopsy tells you what is
happening now and can be followed for
changes over time
so you might need one tumor biopsy but
you'd like to not have to stick a needle
in the liver or the lungs or the bone
all the time and if you could reliably
draw blood and see what molecular
changes there are
that would be incredibly useful so this
is how i am generally ordering my blood
my
molecular evaluation of people with
metastatic breast cancer
from a blood test and i think this is
becoming the key practice
so i've covered a lot of ground i've
almost lost my voice as you can tell
but in summary hitting the high points
biomarkers are critical to define breast
cancer subtypes that predict prognosis
and guide treatment
we need biomarkers still to better
define when to escalate or de-escalate
therapy
and to identify patients with early
stage cancer will benefit from our novel
therapies
biomarkers can be useful in evaluation
of symptoms in survivors
but should not be used without patients
without symptoms outside of a clinical
trial
we certainly need more research into
biomarkers that can identify high-risk
patients
who can be targeted for early
intervention and improved outcomes
such as tumor markers and high-risk
patients and further exploring the
potential
of circulating tumor dna biomarkers as
i've shown you are critical to guide
selection of
therapy and metastatic disease and
increasingly so
we've got fda approved biomarker driven
new drugs
but our are testing them is now ahead of
our routine testing the clinic
so i'd like to see these things be
automated so i don't need to remember to
send a pi3 kinase test
it'll be done in all of my patients with
er positive breast cancer
we're not there yet um biomarkers can be
used as one of the tools
to evaluate response to therapy as long
as we don't over interpret them
and liquid biopsies is an early
screening of response and guide to
precision therapy
is clearly the future for those of you
who are in pathology or in research
uh i would you know highly just from my
perspective as a medical oncologist
that's the way the field is moving those
are the tests i'm most interested in
ordering
so i'll leave you with the words of the
asco guideline panel from 2015
this era of molecular medicine and
patient-centered care it is critical
that the medical community continue to
lobby for
and conduct high-quality biomarker
research for women with advanced breast
cancer
as we've seen even since those
guidelines we've got new validated
biomarkers and new fda approved drugs to
use
and outcomes and prognosis is getting
better so thank you very much for
being with me through this discussion of
biomarkers and breast cancer
thank you dr peppercorn for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move on to the q a portion
of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
our first question is dr peppercorn you
have touched
base on screening and asymptomatic
patients and how using biomarkers might
not be as useful
how would you treat patients with high
risk of breast cancers
would you still not choose biomarkers to
screen especially in young patients it's
a it's a good question and it's a really
tough question
um it comes up all the time in clinic um
because we do tell people they're at
risk we give them all these
interventions
and and then we worry um and i'll say
this part of managing fear of recurrence
which is not exactly what you asked
about
but part of managing that is simply to
acknowledge that it's a very real thing
that many people experience
and it's normal in terms of biomarkers
being the answer to that or being the
answer to help
find things early the fact is that we
just don't have
evidence yet that screening an
asymptomatic patient of any age
and of any risk leads to any clinical
benefit
so we've got clinical validity for the
biomarkers but we don't have clinical
utility
uh for the testing to change what you do
and
so so outside of um outside of a
clinical trial
i'm really not testing biomarkers
routinely in somebody without symptoms
um but i also have a very low threshold
and frankly almost all of us have
symptoms at different times fatigue
you know and usually i'm not suspicious
depending on the symptom
the cancer is the answer but it's
reasonable
to check biomarkers if there's something
going on and i think you have to do it
particularly for your high risk patients
at a lower threshold than you would for
a very low risk patient
so that tends to be how i use them in
practice
and that's consistent with the
guidelines but i guess i would also just
want to add
that we clearly need better studies and
research
looking at these high risk groups you
know young patients for sure
positive lymph nodes the subtypes that i
mentioned that are that are more
dangerous
to see if screening bio screening for
biomarkers
in asymptomatic patients can lead to
early diagnosis
and can lead to improving the cure rate
it's possible that it could it really
hasn't been clearly established one way
or the other
okay thank you our last question here
is what are your thoughts about imaging
versus using biomarkers in breast cancer
screening and monitoring
i think we're probably talking about
metastatic patients there um
and clearly you need to image it's
absolutely standard practice
you're gonna get scans anywhere from uh
every two to four months initially
every three to four months down the road
and sometimes if someone's doing well
for a long time six months um
so the question is really how do
biomarkers fall in as an adjunct to that
and what you know
is either one of them the gold standard
um i guess
i would say that i use that stool as i
described always
much more frequently than imaging asking
patients how things are going and if
they things do not seem to be going well
i may get the scan earlier and i will be
getting biomarkers
not all patients with metastatic breast
cancer have elevated cea and ca 2729 or
ca 15-3
if i test it baseline they're not
elevated even though they've diseased
then
we don't use them but if they are
elevated um they're often a very useful
tool
and i use them in addition one thing to
highlight is especially with
immunotherapies now
you can have a scan that actually looks
worse because
it's the immune response to the tumor so
it's it's sort of a
pseudo progression um where it looks a
little bigger on scans
but it actually reflects a favorable
response to treatment it will lead to a
good outcome
and this is where biomarkers in
particular can be very useful
to figure out what's going on in the
cancer so we try not to use any one tool
in that stool alone we use them all in
combination
thank you again dr jeffrey peppercorn
and thank you to the audience for your
outstanding questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on our other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
goodbye